le gros message que la direction cherche
à nous faire passer à l'heure actuelle
c'est de toute manière en europe
il n'y a pas d'avenir pour des activités
de fabrication on les transfère en inde
et en chine
ils sont venus dénoncer le plan de
restructuration engagé par general
electric
les syndicats nationaux ont rejoint les
salariés de l'entreprise américaine sur
le site de belfort des salariés inquiets
pourtant peu nombreux à se mobiliser
franchement je suis très très déçu je
pensais que les gens
ce serait vraiment mobilisé je pense que
les gens sont assez désabusé
malgré tout et je pense qu'on ne peut
plus rien faire on n'a plus
d'interlocuteur ici pratiquement en
france moi j'ai l'impression qu'il ya
pas de pilote dans l'avion et que et
qu'on pilote a vu juste pour faire de
l'argent à court terme mais c'est toi en
2015 l'entreprise avait promis de créer
1000 emplois en france mais c'est accor
s'achève à la fin de l'année partout en
europe des postes sont supprimés alors
les salariés de belfort craignent de ne
pas être épargné pour la france en ce
moment nous sommes en sursis
il ya eu un plan un accord de création
de 1000 emplois les emplois ne sont pas
créés mais pour l'instant il nous
protège des pans licenciement tous les
sites au monde de ji ont été touchées
sauf les sites français et nous pensons
qu'à partir de janvier 2019 mais ils
protègeront toucher les syndicats ont
lancé une pétition ils demandent au
gouvernement de signer de nouveaux
accords avec l'entreprise américaine qui
garantirait notamment les emplois du
territoire français